[Music]
finally Spider-Man 4 marks the big
meeting between Tom Holland Spider-Man
and Tom Hardy's Venom this and lots of
other hot news awaits you right now in
this week's Koch Che
news it's time for round four after
Creed 3 Rocky's Legacy also proved to be
extremely successful there's now nothing
standing in the way of part 4 it is to
be directed once again by Michael B
Jordan producer Irwin Winkler revealed
to Deadlock that Creed 4 is now
officially in development after a delay
due to the actors and writer strike a
really good story has already been found
for part 4 of the popular boxing film
series following his directing debut
with Creed 3 Michael B Jordan will once
again return for part four in a dual
function namely as director and lead
actor this announcement is likely to
create anticipation among fans as part
three is considered the most successful
installment of the series with box
office takings of over $275 million and
was able to impress critics and fans
alike the release date for Creed 4 is
not yet known however the film is set to
begin pre-production next year which
would make a 2025 release feasible we're
definitely excited and looking forward
to more spectacular
fights no Superman without Lex Luther
for some time now there has been a hot
candidate for the cast of the villain in
Superman Legacy the kickoff to the new
DCU and indeed actor Nicholas halt is
set to take on the role of the iconic
antagonist now that David cornet and
Emmy winner Rachel brahan have been cast
in the roles of Superman and Lois Lane
it seems that things are also moving
forward on the antagonist side as
deadline reports the role of the popular
antagonist Lex Luther is to be played by
Nicholas halt halt thus follows in the
footsteps of Jee Hackman Kevin spy and
Jesse Eisenberg who played the character
prior to him the actress Maria Gabriella
de Faria was cast a week earlier for the
role of the engineer this character's
body has been altered by nanotechnology
which allows her to transform herself
into various things and connect directly
to computers the screenplay and
direction will be handled by DC boss
James gun himself Superman Legacy will
be released in cinemas on July 11th 2025
and will be the first film in the new
DCU film Universe which is set to
replace the old DCU however fans of DC
movies won't have to miss out in 2024
either while we eagerly await the new
Superman film Joker 2 F you do the
sequel to the mega hit starring Wen
Phoenix will be released on October 4th
are we finally getting the Spidey and
Venom clash in a report by Hollywood
Insider Daniel Rickman it is said that
Spider-Man 4 will finally close the gap
between the MCU and the SSU the chaotic
right situation regarding the friendly
neighborhood spider runs like a Common
Thread through the Marvel Universe on
the one hand there's the MCU with Tom
Holland in the role of the iconic spider
while on the other hand Sony continues
to expand its own film Universe with
movies such as Venom 3 Madam web and
Craven the hunter the two Studios have
already worked together on Spider-Man no
way home Raising Hope among fans that
the two universes could possibly merge
after all this possibility now seems
more realistic than ever Hollywood
Insider Daniel Rickman reports that the
upcoming Spider-Man 4 will finally see
the two universes merge with reference
to the Multiverse this plays an
important role in the current MCU anyway
and Tom Hardy's appearance in the
post-credit scenes in no way home was
already an indication of this the
existing characters from the SSU and the
MCU could therefore be brought together
and meet Spider-Man it remains to be
seen whether this will happen in the end
next year we can expect a bunch of new
Sony films Madam web Venom 3 and Craven
the hunter could possibly provide new
clues about the crossover we're looking
forward to
it what a sensation in a jointly
published video Jackie Chan and Ralph
machio announced that they would be
starring together in the next The Karate
Kid installment another movie of the
popular The Karate Kid franchise which
was last rebooted over 13 years ago is
set for release next year another part
is to follow in which Ralph machio the
karate kid from the first movie in 1984
and Jackie Chan are to come together the
two actors announced this via a video
and also disclosed that they are
currently looking to cast the new main
character the new Karate Kid Bears the
role name Lee Fong and will be a
teenager between the ages of 15 and 17
of Chinese descent the character is
described as smart Scrappy and a skilled
martial artist Jackie Chan already
started in the reboot as the main
character's Mentor while Ralph machio
also reprised his role in the spin-off
series Cobra Kai the new Karate Kid
movie will be directed by Jonathan
Entwistle who is best known for his
Netflix series I am not okay with this
the screenplay is by author Rob Lieber
who previously worked on Peter Rabbit
and goosebumps 2 the theatrical release
for the new movie is slated for December
13th
2024 a shock for all fans of the iconic
serial killer the scream franchise has
lost another protagonist for part seven
namely Jenna Ortega leaving the
franchise unsure of its future only
recently lead actress Melissa Barrera
was fired from the production after she
repeatedly attracted attention with
anti-semitic statements on social media
she previously played Sam Carpenter one
of the main characters in the new Scream
movies Jenna Ortega is now also leaving
Scream 7 this news comes from The
Hollywood Reporter which revealed that
Ortega would be unable to participate
due to the filming of the second season
of Wednesday the actress is also said to
have demanded significantly more money
which the production company spy glass
entertainment was unwilling to pay like
many horror faks this franchise has
benefited from being produced at
relatively low cost so the series has
always been very lucrative even if it
hasn't attracted as many viewers as the
big Blockbusters nevertheless things are
looking pretty bad at the moment when it
comes to the future of Scream 7 and
accordingly fans are asking themselves
the bid question of how the movie could
be made without the involvement of the
two actresses variety reports that a
complete reboot could now be imminent
with the focus once again being placed
more on the characters from the old
movies apparently Nev Campbell and
Patrick Dempsey are at the very top of
the wish list for those in charge it
remains to be seen whether and how
Scream 7 will turn out one thing is
certain though the project is being
worked on at full speed in order to
ensure a release date in late 2024 or
spring
2025 a new mission for Jason Bourne
after five successful films from the
Jason Bourn Universe Universal has now
officially commissioned part six which
is to be directed by German director
Edward burer but now the big question is
will Matt Damon return it has been 7
years since we enjoyed the last Jason
born Adventure the action thrillers
starring Matt Damon and Alicia bander
was a great success with box office
takings of $414 million raising the
question of what the future holds for
the franchise as deadline now reports
Universal Pictures is said to have given
the green light for part six which will
be directed by All Quiet on the Western
Front director Edward berer so far no
other names have been associated with
the project besides Burger but industry
insiders assume that Matt Damon will be
returning in his iconic role Damon has
already emphasized several times in the
past that an exciting story would be a
decisive factor for him to work on
further Jason born movies accordingly
the script must first be written before
we can speculate about Damon's comeback
should the actor not return there is of
course the possibility of a reboot or a
prequel for which a younger actor could
be cast there should definitely be no
lack of exciting stories as we have
already event presented with two
alternative spin-offs of the franchise
with the series treadstone and the born
legacy starring Jeremy
rener all right guys do you happen to be
a huge Disney fan well we got you
covered in our latest movie preview we
take a look at Frozen 3 and introduce
you to some reasonable plot theories
should you be less into Disney and more
into gaming don't worry we also have a
preview for The Fallout Amazon series on
our Channel and the series does look
hella promising apart from that what do
you think of this week's news and which
movies are you looking forward to the
most share your excitement in the
comments and give us a thumbs up if you
like our weekly News videos thanks for
watching and see you next
[Music]
time